why did you write party girl
I wrote party girl when I was four years
sober and I realized the pr about
recovery was so bad and that if I had
had any idea how fun and funny
um and joyful recovery would be I
wouldn't have had to go as low as I did
and so I thought what if I could tell a
story if I can help one person see that
it's not recovery is not the end of life
but the beginning I will have done
something good
how long did it take you to write it I
wrote party girl very quickly I had no
idea how to write a book I just was very
Brazen and just was like well I've read
novels I will just write this and so I
started writing it and I actually had
one friend who was a novelist and I was
with her one day and she was saying to
me oh God when I started off I didn't
have a clue I mean I didn't even know
novels had a three-act structure and I
remember going you didn't and then I
race home and I look and I have like 400
pages of one act I had no idea there was
supposed to be a structure I didn't know
anything and so that was the process of
you know what Stephen King calls killing
Your Darlings and I just you know got
rid of excise 350 pages that day
and this was in the mid 90s the I wrote
the book I I got sober in 2000 and I
started and I wrote party girl in 2004
sold it to harpercollins in 2005 and it
came out in 2007. and where did you
actually write the book oh physically
where was I I was in my apartment on
Sweetser Avenue in um in West Hollywood
and anybody who's lived in La everyone's
either lived on sweets or Sycamore or
has dated somebody who's lived on
sweetstar Sycamore it's just an LA thing
tell me about the bidding war for the
book I know I'm jumping ahead a little
bit oh it was so exciting a bidding war
might be over staining things but it was
this completely Cinderella experience
because I had been working on this book
and literally an agent emails me out of
the blue and says I really like your
magazine work so it wasn't completely
out of the blue because I was well known
as a magazine writer and he said I I
think you're really funny if you ever
have a book let me know and I write them
back and say that's crazy I just
finished writing a book he said I'm
gonna be in L.A tomorrow let's sign and
I said fantastic and the next day I wake
up and there's an email from a different
agent and she says I just read a bunch
of your magazine stories I think you're
really talented if you ever have a book
tell me so I write her back and I say
that is so crazy I'm going to sign with
an agent literally walking out the door
and she said send me your phone number
and she called me and she she said do me
a favor do not sign with this person
today give me one day I'll cancel the
rest of my day and I'll read your book
if I don't like it you don't have a
problem go sign with him if I like it
you've got to give me a shot and so I
went to lunch with this guy I said I
know I said I was signing but I'm not
signing and she loved the book and she
said I can sell this and the way we're
gonna do this is if you just give a book
to editors they they take forever to
read it so I'm gonna say Anna's come to
town in two days so if you want a shot
at this you got to meet her and you have
to have read it before you meet with her
and I said but I'm not coming to town in
two days and she said well the worst
that can happen is you'll lose money on
a ticket and a hotel but I think I can
sell this so and that was a lot of money
to me at the time so I go to New York I
go to these two meetings with her and
then on my second day we get a call from
Regan books and Regan was like Judith
Regan in the 90s was the biggest deal
publisher my wildest dreams I didn't
think that I could attract a Judith
Regan we get a call when I'm already
there and they say Judith Regan not her
herself although anyway they said Regan
wants to meet with you so we go in we
meet with them I go home and I and and
pillar my agent says you know we'll know
by Monday all weekend long I'm just like
I promise I'll be happy for the rest of
my life if this book can sell she calls
me Monday morning and she tells me that
the two places pass
I'm devastated and then you know I'm
like the dream's over and she calls me
back she goes reading books made an
offer and and I and I did say I'm gonna
be happy for the rest of my life and I
was for about two weeks and then I
realized oh no thing ever actually makes
you happy
at any point in the editors reading the
book or Judith Regan reading the book
did they say can you tone it down a
little bit or can you ramp it up a
little bit
you know they never said tone it down
you know the one thing they said tone
down I I talked about like God and
spirituality and they were like that
really makes people uncomfortable and
this is of course two years before a
book called Eat Pray Love Comes Out
nobody's freaked out about God At All by
then but that was the one thing they
wanted me to tone down in fact the note
I got when they bought the book was
and I'm not saying this in a
self-aggrandizing way they were just
like it's so perfect it's like you don't
you didn't make any mistakes because I
come from a world of being a writer and
an editor and you don't you turn in work
that you have edited and re-edited and
re-edited and I don't know that the book
world was used to that they were used to
typos so yeah all I had to do was like
take out some of the god stuff and we
were good is that because they thought
that the the some of the topics in it
maybe the salacious Parts wouldn't mix
with the religion I don't know I think
that there are certain words that freak
people out and God is one of them and so
I think that Publishers just like many
people just want to take the safest
route they want to not alienate people
not freak people out maybe they didn't
think it went with all the like crazy
sex and drugs and rock and roll stuff
but but I I just said sure whatever you
want you guys know
how soon after the book was published
did you sell the movie rights the
there was an interest in the movie
rights before the book came out and I'm
not entirely sure how it happened but
sort of knowledge about the book and its
topic leaked out so there was interest
you know between a publisher acquiring a
book and releasing it it's like a year
or two it just takes forever so during
that time I live in Hollywood I was
hearing from people so I I signed with
CAA CA was interested in representing
the book
um and so
I the the actual story about what
happened is I got this agent who
couldn't have cared less couldn't have
cared less so there everybody who made
an offer told me they had to pursue and
pursue and pursue him to even get a call
back other friends told me they were
like your book landed on my desk with no
cover letter and no explanation so in
spite of the lack of interest of my
agent there was a bidding war over it
um but it was it was really frustrating
when you're a small like you know when
you're at one of those big agencies and
you're not a huge huge star that's what
happens but
um but yeah and so
the story of the movies amazing do you
want me to go into that now okay so so
the very first offer
um we got a mother-daughter team who had
a deal at Sony said to me they came to
me and they were wooing me and we had
lunch at this place called Michael's in
New York which is probably long gone but
it was this fancy publishing place and
they said if you go with us we will get
whatever screenwriter you want and I was
obsessed with Reality Bites so I said if
you can get the woman who wrote Reality
Bites to write my that my story I'm in
and they come back and they said we got
her her name's Helen Childress she's
excited here's your check and they
optioned it for twenty thousand dollars
which to me now is a fortune because now
they don't really pay anything for
options but at the time I didn't know
anything I was like great
so then everybody's very excited we're
talking about Lindsay Lohan who was a
big star at the time and they wanted to
sell it to Lifetime and I just thought
this sounds great this sounds like it's
going to be made and other offers were
coming in but I was like committed to
that one so with that one
then one day I email the mother-daughter
team I don't hear back I text them I
don't hear back
um I never hear anything it's all very
Hollywood and one day I get an email
from CA that says congratulations your
rights have reverted back to you and I
wrote back and I said what does this
mean never heard back Google it it means
oh your movie wanted to turn around it
means like this is not good news and so
years pass and I was a freelance
magazine writer still and one time I
wrote a story about this experience
saying
um oh and it was all about Reality Bites
and how Troy Dyer who was the main
character in Reality Bites how he ruined
my whole like identification about
dating and how I was always seeking Troy
die or the most screwed up man ever and
I put as an aside
um I heard a rumor that the woman who
wrote Reality Bites wrote the party girl
script but I never even found out if
that was true sometimes reality really
does bite okay
Helen Childress saw the story and emails
me and says oh my god did you seriously
never see the script that I wrote of
party girl and I wrote back and said I
didn't even think they were telling the
truth I never even heard from them again
and she sent me the script so there it
is like early so it's like 2011 I'm
reading my favorite screenwriters
version of my book which is based on my
life from 10 years before it was the
most surreal experience ever and I said
to her oh let's let's get the movie
going again but when it once it's in
turn around
um it's that's almost impossible so do
you think the lesson though among others
is that
word gets out without you knowing how
and also no one tells you anything
yeah I mean Hollywood's an evil place
I'm sure everyone knows that but you
know it's it's basically you know when
when I have a book a story like this
which has been around now for 15 years
and I have seen every incarnation of
producer coming along and I'm whined and
I'm dying not really wine but you know
and they're just like this is gonna be
it we're gonna do this and we're gonna
go there and then literally you never
hear from them again I've now lived in
La for so long that I'm used to this
sort of treatment I'm just like oh okay
so you don't you don't you you never
hear again you don't we don't really
live in a Hollywood is not a place where
anybody even really tells you when
they've gone off and moved on to the
next hot thing you just have to figure
it out
how did you get a meeting with Martin
scorsese's producer
um this is a great story I am friends
with this couple who have these
get-togethers in LA with hundreds of
people where basically they'll sort of
interview
usually famous people and everybody's
watching and then they sometimes have
friends or just people with interesting
careers so they were interviewing me in
front of this crowd of about a hundred
people at their place in in Bel Air and
they were just interviewing me about
publishing and why should people write
books and somebody came up to me
afterwards and he said
um are you a screenwriter because you
talk like a screenwriter and I said no
but I have this book that would make the
best movie and he said well great I'm a
producer and that was his name is Niels
Joel and we were uh you know we worked
together I mean it was a long time it
was a couple years where he tried to
sell it and he wasn't able to
um but yeah he's great
how does a book or novel get on the
radar of Hollywood and Hollywood
producers
it
it is okay a book gets on the radar
either because it sells like crazy
um it doesn't sell like crazy but gets a
lot of buzz like party girl the it
didn't sell that many copies but a lot
of people were talking about it or
because a book scout finds it and I
think with El James and Fifty Shades of
Gray it really opened up Hollywood to
this idea that a book does not have to
be traditionally published for it to
make a movie and then Andy Weir wrote
The Martian and then
um so so
people can't producers can't just look
at what is on the New York Times
bestseller list what's in airport
bookstores they actually have to like
have a much wider swath of where they're
looking to find the books
why do you think Hollywood keeps buying
the rights to your book but not making
the movie
Hollywood loves to buy the rights to
things and not make them
um I think you know it's probably three
percent of the books that are optioned
are actually made and you know I just
think that everybody in Hollywood
there's somebody else that they're
answering to and most people are sort of
coming from a place of fear and what
just hit and what you know and so they
just want to have as many options as
possible literally book options as
possible knowing that they're only going
to take a tiny fraction of them
and tie them up so that others can't
yeah get to it before they do okay yeah
that's interesting when I um this is
this is kind of interesting when I used
to do coverage when my first jobs when I
first moved to LA so I would read
screenplays and you know basically write
book reports on them and I remember
there was this book
um that came out and I read coverage on
it and I just thought this is the worst
book I have ever read and I wrote
coverage saying this is the worst book I
have ever read this is why I get called
into the office the next day and my boss
says to me there was a betting War over
that book yesterday and it sold for
three million dollars now why are you
saying what you said and I said because
it's true it's terrible I later many
years later became friends with the
studio head who had made that who bought
it for three million dollars and he goes
oh yeah that book was terrible I had to
keep it out of someone else's hands so
that's why we did it so
um you know there are all sorts of
reasons that Hollywood digs into its
Deep Pockets to buy things
how much money can an author expect to
make on their first book let's say they
have a publisher involved well
publishing has changed so much since
when I got into it in 2005.
um back then I will tell you I'm very
I'm always very tacky and open about
money I got paid fifty thousand dollars
for my first book from harpercollins and
I was devastated because I knew all
these people who were making you know
getting hundreds of thousands of dollars
this was actually almost at the same
time that Hollywood was paying a lot of
money for spec scripts too
now I hear about advances that are five
to ten thousand dollars
publishing is an even more broken
business than Hollywood the way
publishing works is that they know
they're going to really make the bulk of
their money off of probably one or two
books all year and they're going to put
all their marketing and all their
promotion and all their efforts between
you know into those few books and they
consider everything else just a loss
leader they're just sort of throwing it
out you know 99 of books do not earn out
their advance so and the way that works
is so I was paid fifty thousand dollars
so then harpercollins has a situation
where they've got they're going to spend
fifty thousand dollars on you know the
editing and the cover and all of the
things and then once it comes starts to
come in then you know you split your
percentage with your publisher I've
never earned out most authors have never
earned out so obviously if you get a
lower Advance you're gonna earn out more
quickly
but basically the way the way publishing
works is there are these books that are
you know the 50 Shades of Gray the Eat
Pray Love The Glenn and Doyle books
whatever those are and they most of the
population doesn't read so for a book to
hit basically it has to hit a segment of
the population that doesn't read where
people are going to be going to parties
and someone will say oh did you read Eat
Pray Love or did you read 50 Shades of
Gray and they're going to feel stupid
that they haven't read it so a book just
goes crazy when people who don't even
read books are reading it
um and so and so those are the books
there's just there's no there used to be
something called the mid list author the
midlist author would sell you know 5 000
copies of a book 8 000 copies of the
book now it's just the millions and
millions or the people that are selling
you know books under a thousand copies
what about if you become a New York
Times best-selling author how does life
change that is interesting because it
you can hit the New York Times
bestseller list selling 3000 copies it's
all depends on what else is being
released that week and you know the
Bible has never hit the New York Times
bestseller list because it's about the
amount of sales in a particular week
any of the New York Times list as
opposed to the Wall Street journalists
or the USA Today list they admit that it
is a sort of editorial decision it's
actually William blatty who wrote The
Exorcist his
second book Legion
he sued the New York Times because he
said you know this was only briefly on
the list I know how many copies it sold
it went to court and New York Times said
in court this is actually an editorial
decision so that is something that uh
they are they they admitted in court
so the big misconception is that if you
hit the New York Times list you're set
for life not at all true I know
so many New York Times best-selling
authors who are completely broke and I
know people who have self-published
books that have sold 200 copies that are
living large so I was never more broke
than when I was a New York Times
best-selling author
was that perception an eye-opener for
you I know you said that you thought
once you sell these rights once you get
this book life will be wonderful I
said publishing inspires more delusions
than Hugh Grant movies people go into it
I was one of them you go in and you have
this book and everyone says to you like
don't get your hopes up you know this
phone doesn't happen for very many
people and you're like yeah yeah it's
gonna be different for me and I
experience it and I have now witnessed
probably hundreds of people I know who
have done the same thing and I can tell
when I'm talking to them and I and I try
to you know give them my gentle love of
like no no no this doesn't work don't
compare yourself to the exception you
know compare yourself to the rule and
and they just kind of give me this look
of like no it'll be different for me so
I have found I have never been someone
whose life has changed overnight as a
result of anything I know that does
happen to people but I also know people
who had
crazy hits out of the gate their first
book went crazy and they spend the rest
of their career living in like the glory
of their past I wouldn't want that
either I want my greatest success to be
in front of me not behind me
right I think it was an Elizabeth
wurtzel uh Prozac or yeah and David
Foster wall yeah they had had these hits
right out of the gate and I know and I
know other people who are still alive
who that happened to as well right and
there's other things that come with it
too because I think then you're kind of
always like sneer dad in that world
because you're the one that was the was
the darling out of the gate and I think
that's a hard thing to live up to as
well I think it is I think it is I mean
yeah right right but anyway it's
different I know I get it it's going to
be different for me yeah and right every
it's always different what if you
self-publish what is money like then
well I will say when I was being
traditionally published my first book
deal was fifty thousand dollars I did
five more deals my final book deal was
for two thousand dollars two thousand
dollars so it worked out to about I
guess like a quarter of a penny a day
for like my amount of work
no money comes from Book Sales like I
will say this until I'm like blue in the
face so self-publishing yes you can make
more money from Book Sales because your
percentage is going to be higher but
never look at it as the book sales I'm
obsessed with like what is the back end
so I write books now that bring people
they bring attention to my company they
add to my credibility as a publisher as
an author as all of these things so yeah
I'll make like a couple thousand dollars
on Book Sales but I can bring in
hundreds of thousands of dollars in new
clients so I think the whole perception
has to change when we're talking about
money just not even I wanted to start a
podcast called like screw Book Sales
like it's not about the book sales it's
about there's no better credibility
Builder there's no better business card
there's no better way to say I am an
expert than to publish a book book so
why would you do that be the world be
one of the world's experts and have
everyone want to hire you and be worried
about the counting the Pennies on the
book sales it just doesn't make sense
when you talked about Bill blatty or
William blatty uh you know with the
Exorcist and then he had several other
books I believe you said there was this
this lawsuit back then was it more what
people expect and it's drastically
changed now
Bezos changed publishing when
self-publishing went from like your
creepy uncle's book that was like the
the garage was filled with this book he
was always passing out you know family
reunions that was self-publishing when
Amazon changed and they created
um KDP where anybody could actually go
in and publish a book it changed
everything I mean self-publishing isn't
new Stephen King his self-published Jane
Austen self-published it's not new but
the way it can be done now the level at
which it can be done it's
indistinguishable from a traditionally
published New York Times best-selling
book so the thing the problem with that
is that people go great I mean we could
in the next 10 minutes publish a book on
Amazon that doesn't mean it's going to
be good
um but so the distinction Now isn't
between what's traditionally published
and what's self-published but what's
published at the highest level and what
isn't published the highest level what
are the different ways that an author is
paid
so you mean with traditional or just in
general or self yeah
um so if you're traditionally published
you're paid your Advance which is
usually broken up into threes which is
you know here's here's the third then
the second third is when you turn it in
and then the third third is when you
release it if you're self-published or
you're paying a company to publish
you're gonna put the money out and then
it's up to you how you want to make the
money back
um what we do for our clients will put a
QR code at the beginning of the book If
you put it at the beginning of the book
because of Amazon's look inside feature
people who don't even buy the book could
theoretically get whatever it is so
people put on QR codes on the beginning
of their book they can you can put on
the QR on the barcode on the back you
can put it throughout and people do all
sorts of things there are um there is a
a writer named he's a marketer writer
named Pat Flynn who put a he has a book
called will it Fly great book and it's
all about like is your business idea
viable he created a free course that the
there's links throughout the book to the
free course from that free course the
people who signed up he sold them a paid
course and um the person who helped him
do that I had on my podcast and he said
through that he made a hundred and
eleven thousand dollars not from his
full email list just from the list of
the people who read the book and signed
up for the free course I don't know many
authors that are making a hundred and
eleven thousand dollars on their launch
day but that's the kind of thing that's
possible what do you mean when you say
you're not going to make money from Book
Sales so the book should be about your
secret power
I mean that that people read a how-to
book because they want to solve a
problem they want to know how to do
something and so a book should show
somebody who wants to know how to do
something how they can do it but at the
same time show how much more complicated
the thing is to do than they might have
thought so somebody who could afford to
would then want to pay somebody to do it
for them and who better to pay than the
person who wrote the book on the topic
on top of the advance what about
royalties
well you're talking to someone who never
earned royalties
um because they you don't royalties
don't kick in until after they have paid
out the advance so so that's why authors
who just get like you know no advance or
very minimal advances can earn back the
I don't know the exact percentages
because it's never been relevant for me
but trust me it's not in the author's
favor
so the more you get up front almost like
a film distribution deal the better you
are are you getting an accounting every
month
yes I mean my accountings are terribly
depressing
um yeah I mean you get an account uh I
still think I get accountings on books
of mine where they're like no book sales
for this month or whatever it is but um
but yeah like I said I just think
looking at the book sales is is a losing
game
do you own the rights to all of your
books I only own the rights to party
girl and then uh how to get Successful
by effing up your life and make your
mess your Memoir I sold uh the rights to
five of my books to Harper and then one
to Simon and Schuster with party girl I
was able to get the rights back which
was an incredible thing because I knew
the movie was gonna get made and I
always hated the cover and I just
basically decided Well Harper Collins
doesn't care about this book I really
care about this book when the book came
out Judith Regan had been fired in the
worst Scandal to ever hit publishing so
all these High Hopes they had for the
book there wasn't you know they talk in
publishing about if your editor leaves
to go to another house you've been
orphaned and I always said it's like the
I was orphan and the orphanage was built
to the ground there was there was no
office anymore so back then in 2007
bookstores mattered a lot lot and the
way Publishers got books into bookstores
is they would send sales representatives
there were no sales representatives so
the book was sort of DOA even though
there was all this buzz and all the
movie rights and all of these things in
order to get the rights back my contract
um stipulated that I got them back
within 10 years but we still had to get
it official and so it was very
complicated my lawyer sent um a lot you
know letters to Harper Collins but
because the division was gone there was
no one to approve it I had to get my
agent involved and then finally at a
certain point I said I don't care I
don't think Harper's gonna care if I
re-release it so I had my cover designer
do this amazing cover I decided I wanted
to release it in September because it
was addiction recovery month and I was
like you know what they can come after
me hey it'll be good publicity if they
actually care and I already had plans to
release the book and the the day before
I get a letter it's like congratulations
you've got your rights back and I'm like
thanks didn't even need it no Scandal
darn okay yeah
is 10 years a common length of time I
actually don't know I don't know
um I think when a publisher really
values a book that they're gonna fight
to keep it but it was almost like they
cared so little that's why it was hard
to get them back because there was just
no one who was even involved anymore
is being an author your dream job all I
ever wanted was to be an author the 1976
Guinness Book of World Records showed I
was six and it showed the youngest
author was four
Dorothy Straight and I cried and said I
can't be the youngest author like that's
how long I've wanted to do it
um it is my dream job being able
being an author and and selling my books
to companies and being traditionally
published was actually a total nightmare
being able to be an author who publishes
my own books and gets to kind of do it
for fun is my dream job absolutely
do you wish you could just be an author
and not have to run your own company
such a good question no I love doing all
of it I it's not that I feel badly for
people who say that they write all day
but I think
that sounds kind of boring I love that I
get to write I get to make podcasts I
get to talk to clients I get to go do
speaking I I need the variety and I will
tell you I had years when I lived in New
York and I was just on contract writing
books for Harper Collins and my whole
life was sitting in my depressing studio
apartment with my two cats writing books
and to me I know that's a dream for some
people
not for me I I'm I approach writing like
a job I always think that when people
talk about writer's block I'm like oh
does the bricklayer walk wake up and go
I don't feel inspired I just don't think
I can lay a brick you know if you're a
writer you know have the self-respect to
do it every day and so when I was
writing books my deal with myself was I
will write three pages a day but I can't
write my three pages till I revise my
three pages from the day before
first time authors I don't recommend
revising as you go you should just get
your first draft out but that's how I
write books that's not fun I want to
have different things I don't it's very
isolating to write full time
well for someone who's an extrovert and
I know you said you're you're an
extrovert yeah that that does seem
difficult for those who are more
introverted and they you know it's
almost like they dread going to the
grocery store do you think that would be
a dream job or even for that type of
person it would still get depressing
I don't know I can't really get in
someone else's head but I will say the
people who tell me oh I just want to I
wish I could write full time they're
never the people who do I think
everything sounds better than it
actually is but I think I think
um
I think we also need experiences to have
things to write about if we're doing
non-fiction it's like you can't just
hole up and and have a whole world that
you can write about
that's a great point and so when you are
busy doing other things you're gonna
you're getting material yeah great
material if someone came to you and said
all I want to do is be an author that's
all I want to do what would you tell
them oh it happens to me every day
um I say great what's your business and
they say oh I don't have a business I
just want to be an author and then I'll
say why and they say well I really want
to help people with my story and I say
that's amazing go volunteer it's going
to be a lot it's a it's a much easier
way to help people if the average book
sells 300 copies and you could go out
and volunteer and help more than 300
people in a week that's going to be a
more fruitful use of your time
um I do not believe the profession of
author really exists today even the most
successful ones I mean I guess JK
Rowling Glennon Doyle Glennon Doyle's
doing podcasts doing speeches you know I
don't even think that's a job anymore
but for at least
99.999 percent of us it's not a viable
job I like I said when I was working on
that book I think I made a quarter of a
penny a day I think writers I think all
creatives should have the self-respect
to say I should be compensated
appropriately for what I'm doing I will
have people who say you know they maybe
don't say this to me but they sort of
think it's crass the way I talk about oh
you need to have a business and it's
like what I'm actually saying is you
should be paid for your work you
shouldn't be doing it for and begging
for pennies you should find a way to be
able to live a Wonderful Life while also
being creative
what if the flip side of the of the
would-be author comes to you and says I
want to be famous I don't care about
helping anybody I want my name on all
the lists
oh
um
you know I think to be
effective
and successful
as an author and to have it really mean
anything you kind of gotta have that
combination of having a really something
that really matters to you and a desire
to share it I don't think there's
anything wrong with wanting to be out
there sharing a message I think we live
in the most magical time we live in a
terrible time in so many ways and yet we
live in the most magical time in terms
of there are no Gatekeepers anymore
anybody can treat social media as their
own Magazine TV station radio station uh
publishing company and and I think so
many people look at it as this Albatross
oh I've got to steep keep putting
content out there what if it's just how
lucky are we that we can sort of be
creative put it out there whenever we
want and that there's no one there to
say no you're not good enough you're not
good enough so we're gonna pick her I I
think it's I think it's amazing so I
think that a lot of people I run into
sort of say well who am I to write a
book why should the world care about
what I have to say and it's like why not
you
why not
so is it almost good to have a little
bit of the of the
um bravado sort of uh you know just
Shameless self-promotion mixed with
some type of for lack of a better term
message
absolutely I think I think that what
people need to remember is
self-promotion is not about you it's
like if if you have a message
um you know if you were covered from
something and most people who are
writing Memoirs or non-fiction books
have struggled with something and come
out on the other side and then they say
well I'm not that into self-promotion
and it's like if there's one person
whose life is going to be saved from
your book you owe it to them it's not
about you it's actually self-obsessed to
not share it because you think that you
know
that's self-obsessed or whatever it is
the average author sells how many copies
around 300.
and this is per year
total total okay yeah I mean there are
so many books being put out now and I
think people have their their numbers
are they're very confused about the
numbers when I and I'm the exact same
when I remember being in the like
elevator at Harper Collins and talking
about the first print run of party girl
and I remember saying yeah What's it
gonna be like 68 000 you know to me when
you don't know you don't know how many
that means any book if you sell 10 000
copies of your book your book has done
very very very well
um you know if those 10 000 sales
happened in a week you're hitting all
the best seller lists so I think people
who even just sell 2 000 or 3 000 copies
of their books should feel really really
really good about it
you think people are reading less now or
actually more because they're using
Kindle and different things like that
it's it's not as far as I know the
statistics on reading haven't changed
it's the volume of books out there when
I published my first book in 2007
there's a fraction of what's available
today
why do most authors fail most authors
fail because they have completely
unrealistic ideas about what being an
author means they think they should be
able to write a book and have everybody
buy it and see their Brilliance that I'm
somebody who had to learn this the hard
way I did it six times failing to ask
myself who is this book for if I had
said that on my first book my career
would be so much different you need to
be able to say who is my book for and
what do I want them to do when they
finished reading it and if you can do
that you're going to be in better shape
than 99.9 percent of authors out there
this is for non-fiction Fiction's a
little bit different but so so I always
with one of my books make your Mr Memoir
I pictured
one couple so it's two people I pictured
them the whole time every page would
they like this would this be too much
for them would this freak them out would
they get that and I highly recommend
that you know this marketing idea is the
riches are in the niches or if your book
is for everyone it's for No One the idea
with a book is you make it for the
smallest group of people possible
because what happens is that small group
the people in that small group read the
book and feel so seen and feel like they
have a book that's so specifically for
them that they go out and they start
recommending it to people now the main
reason we each pick books is somebody
recommended them unlike movies where
you're scrolling or whatever it is most
books are sold because somebody
recommended them so in other words
someone recommending your book means a
lot more than you recommending your book
so if you convert one Niche they become
your spokespeople they become your sales
people they go out and sell your book
for them so yeah so I thought about one
couple thinking you know if they exist
there's a lot of other people like them
you know a lot of people talk about
avatars and figure out you know what it
what kind of car does he drive and well
you know all these things I don't get I
just like to picture one person or a
very small group of people
was this like this this metaphorical
couple that you saw out somewhere where
you thought you know what I bet they
would be into this no it's actually I'll
tell you the story so it's this couple
that I knew from this Mastermind group
that I'm in and I and we had talked
about them hiring my company to do a
book for them and I thought what's the
book I could write that would convince
them that I was the right company to
hire so I write this book I get on Good
Morning America for it we bring in
hundreds of thousands of dollars in new
business they don't hire us because I
don't even think they read it I run into
them maybe a year later and I tell them
the story I go I wrote a book for you I
was thinking about you guys on every
page and they said that's hilarious and
we were it was at a gifting Suite so my
book was there and guess who I'm working
with now them they did hire us wow but
it really was it was really just an
exercise in
I mean my books I'm writing to help
build my business I want to be able to
be creative and the way I can be
creative and not have to worry about
money is if I have a business that it's
bringing people into so I always am
looking at it and I think anybody who
wants to be strategic and smart about it
looks at it like that what what do I
love to do how can I write a book that
will get people to hire me to do it
what does a writer need to know if they
don't want their book to fail
I think writers need to get very clear
about what success and failure means if
if you're relying on the whims of the
universe it's like saying like how do I
not lose at the lotto like you can't
control what other people are going to
do I know I have had very
um successful book launches and
unsuccessful book launches and the
success didn't have to do with how many
books sold it had to do with how I went
into it if you go into a book Lodge and
you're thinking this has to happen and
these number of books have to sell and I
gotta get this review and like you're
setting yourself up for disappointment
if you go in and you sort of
um have have high expectations but keep
them loose and just decide you're going
to have fun with it it's going to be
amazing because if you allow whatever
the universe is going to bring better
things than you want are going to happen
but if you I had I had such miserable
book launches I remember talking to a
friend who said I never feel more sorry
for people than the week of their book
launch because everybody thinks you're
just having this incredible experience
but if you're traditionally published
you're just hearing from your publisher
usually it's not going very well you're
feeling like you got to do everything
you can and you can't control it so I
say you know when I compare how the
party girl launch went in 2007 when
Harper Collins released my book and how
it went in 2021 when I re-released it
myself it was a world of difference but
it was all my attitude
how is a New York Times best-selling
author different from a Wall Street
Journal or USA Today author
the New York Times bestseller list is
the Holy Grail of lists and you know the
New York Times just has a Mystique and
an Allure that no other publication on
Earth does the Wall Street Journal in
USA Today lists are strictly by the
Numbers whereas the New York Times list
yes they're looking at sales numbers but
they're also they've been open about the
fact that it is an editorial decision a
lot of
um people try to game these lists and
there were companies that were allegedly
for two hundred thousand dollars could
get you on the New York Times bestseller
list there was a scandal a few years ago
um a book called handbook for Mortals
came out and it was a why a book and no
one had ever heard of it no one had ever
heard of the author and it it uh hit a
on the New York Times list above of the
hate you give which was a why a book
that everybody was obsessed with and
people said what is this book How come
I've never heard of it Twitter got
involved and they uncovered this thing
that the way they had gotten onto the
New York Times list is they had figured
out which bookstores were New York Times
reporting bookstores so it's sort of
like a Nielsen family some stores report
to the list and you have to have sales
you know you can't go and buy 10 000
copies on Amazon it has to be a little
bit of sales everywhere ever since the
handbook for Mortal Scandal the New York
Times started putting a little dagger
which basically says uh yeah they made
the list but we're not totally sure it's
like it's basically putting it putting
it into question but they still will put
it on the list a lot of people don't
even know what the dagger means uh Wall
Street Journal in USA Today
um strictly by the numbers
if I self-publish my book is there any
way I can become a New York Times
best-selling author with that book you
absolutely can become a New York Times
best-selling author with a
self-published book it doesn't happen
very often but it absolutely can happen
when someone comes to you and says my
goal is to become a New York Times
best-selling author what is your answer
if somebody says my goal is to become a
New York Times best-selling author
um I often will tell them it's like
walking in to buy a lotto ticket and
saying my goal is to be the jackpot
winner that's awesome I think that's
everybody's goal when they played the
lotto but it doesn't mean it's a very
realistic goal I I'm a big fan of those
things you can control uh therefore I
would rather have a hundred people read
one of my books and have those hundred
people incredibly affected by it have
them want to hire me or my company than
have a hundred thousand people who
aren't really going to care I think it
is about the quality of the reader and
the impact the writer is going to have
on them and not about the numbers
what are the biggest misconceptions
people have about being a New York Times
best-selling author the biggest
misconception people have about being in
New York Times best-selling author is
they think you never have to work again
you're a millionaire multi-millionaire
you're made for the rest of your life
the reality is being a New York Times
best-selling author is amazing because
you get to say I'm a New York Times
best-selling author ever trust me I dine
out on it as often as I possibly can
um but it doesn't really mean anything
beyond the fact that you can say it I
know somebody who had a number one New
York Times best-selling book not just on
the list number one on the list for week
after week after week who is completely
broke
so it doesn't mean you're set for life
it just means you've you've accomplished
something that many many people want to
accomplish and you should brag about it
for the rest of your life can you tell
us how you did it how did you become a
New York Times best-selling author well
so my book that hit the list was not
party girl people always I'll tell you
they think it is and sometimes I don't
even correct them I'm like yeah yeah
it's a book uh that I wrote for an actor
um and so we co-wrote it but he actually
never read the book
um and it was what happened is this I
met this actor he said I want to write a
book I said I know an agent who sells
celebrity Memoirs and I called him up
and I said could you sell this book and
he said absolutely and it can be in your
time's best seller and so he he couldn't
make any promises but that's why I
agreed to do it and so it um you know
the actor was able to get on Dr Phil and
on the talk and on these other shows and
it hit the list and
um it doesn't matter if it hits the list
once it doesn't matter if it's the
e-book or the paperback or the hardcover
it doesn't matter if it's there's
something called the extended list if it
hits the list it's officially on the
list so how I did it is basically I
partnered with somebody that um I didn't
want to partner with because I knew that
would be the result or I hoped that
would be the result and that it would
all be worth it
a memoir has a much better chance I
guess of getting a publishing deal and
of of hitting this Mark or no I hear all
sorts of things
um I I don't know
um if I'm you know I think they have
separate lists so I
when I originally wrote party girl I sat
there in the office with Regan books and
they said to me why didn't you write a
memoir and it was the week that James
fry was getting like brought down on
Oprah he had written this recovery book
and it turns out he had made things up
and it was like it happened to be the
week that I was meeting with harp with
uh Regan books about party girl and I
thought well you can't really be funny
in a memoir you can't really make fun of
yourself you can but it's a lot harder
to in retrospect I do wish I had done a
memoir because
you know there's all these lists of like
these are the best you know addiction
Memoirs and all of these things nobody
ever says like here's a list of the most
useful and best addiction novels that's
not really a thing when the book came
out they called it uh what did Harper
came up with
um they called it reality fiction
which is also now called Auto fiction
where it's kind of fiction it's a Romana
clay it's based on your real life but
then there's a lot of fictional elements
to it
can you be a successful author and never
write a New York Times bestseller a
thousand percent a successful author to
me is someone who publishes a book
they're proud of that helps people and
to me it doesn't have to it doesn't mean
a certain number of sales
it means that it's done at the highest
level and it doesn't even have to mean a
certain length there are successful
books that are a hundred Pages
um I don't think you should go any
shorter than that but but there are
horrible books that are on the New York
Times bestseller list like unreadable
books so there is not it there's you
know it's it doesn't mean it's a success
even if it's on a list
to me
do you remember the first Memoir you
read where you said I want to do this
yeah
um I read a book called permanent
midnight by Jerry Stahl in the late 90s
and I thought this is funny this is dark
but this is funny
then
I didn't really think I could do it then
I read this book called going down by
this uh novelist named Jennifer Bell and
it's a novel and it's so funny and I
later became friends with her and she
blurbed one of my later books but I just
I don't know if I thought I was just
like I wish I could do this this is so
funny and I'm a big fan of humorous
writing
um I'm not like I'm like I like
Fitzgerald and not Hemingway Hemingway's
a serious fish sounds fun
um fun but dark that's what I like
um but I will tell you the the way I
actually wrote a book is I was sitting
in
um my old boss's office it was a
magazine that he worked at and I looked
on the shelf and I saw a book written by
a girl we all knew and I picked it up
and I said
what's this and he said oh it's
so-and-so's book and I'm like looked and
it had real pages and a real cover and a
real publisher and I thought if she can
do it I know I can and that's when I sat
down and started writing how much money
can you make as a New York Times
best-selling author
um I will tell you I've never been more
broke than when I was a New York Times
best-selling author that book I had
gotten in advance of
I think it was 75 000 but it took years
of my life between a very unpleasant
years
um between the writing the editing the
the putting it out
um and the way I look at it is there are
businesses where one client could pay
you seventy five thousand dollars a
hundred thousand dollars more than that
so
um
why worry about how much you can make
from an advance or Book Sales when you
can show how well you know how to do
something and have somebody hired to do
that if it's a traditionally published
book that's a lot harder to do because a
traditional publisher they're interested
in bringing people to their publishing
company so so for they put their website
in the book if you're independently or
self-published or hybrid publishing you
get to put your website you get to put a
QR code that brings people to your
newsletter list so so I think the you
know the way to really make money is to
write a book that helps people and helps
someone hire you
what are your thoughts on someone
writing a novel before they write the
screenplay
I think Hollywood is obsessed with IP
intellectual property and I think that
it makes it a lot easier if you can have
a book and also have a screenplay that's
going to put you so far ahead of the
game
do you think someone who's a novelist
can actually write their own screenplay
um I don't think every novelist should
write their own screenplay my experience
when party girl first came out one of
the first people who wanted it was
Melanie Griffith the actress Melanie
Griffith and she contacted me and said
um I want to make this and she was then
married to Antonio Banderas and she said
will you come meet with us and I went to
their house and I met with them and it
was so magical and I sat there with them
and I remember somebody who worked in
the house came in and said uh it's Mr
katzenberg on the line and and so he
left and Melanie goes tell Jeffrey about
party girl and I'm like I'm sure he
doesn't care Melanie wanted me to write
the screenplay she said this is your
story
um let's have you write it and I sat
down and I had no idea what to do many
years passed and then the pandemic hit
my boyfriend happens to not just be a
screenwriter but a structural genius and
he said to me you absolutely could write
this screenplay you just need the
structure I actually had tried to write
scripts in the past and I did actually
even get paid to do one but I really
didn't know what I was doing once he
mapped out the structure for me I just
was able to write it I thought I was
just doing it for fun keep me busy
during a pandemic
um I ended up having some friends read
the screenplay
um my friend Jeff garland from Curb Your
Enthusiasm and then my friend Rebecca De
Mornay who's an actress we did a zoom
reading and I heard that I mean again it
was just kind of for fun and I heard
them and this was good and everybody was
laughing and both of them said to me
afterwards this script works and that's
actually the one that's getting made so
it it took me 15 years to to end the
right structure to realize how to do it
they're definitely different skill sets
but there are definitely people who are
able to write the book and the script
and what is your definition of IP
that's a great question I I mean I think
IP is a book a podcast a YouTube show an
article anything that is the property of
somebody else that somebody could option
and then make into a movie or a TV show
why is it important for a writer to own
their own IP
it's important for a writer to own their
own IP because
we don't have a lot of power the one
thing you've got is your idea and they
can rewrite you and they can you know
they they can take your power away but
if you've got your idea and it's
documented clearly that that's your idea
no one can ever take that away from you
why didn't you originally want to write
the screenplay for party girl I didn't
want to write this screenplay because I
didn't think I knew how and I always
felt like I was hearing stories about
that that Diva person who ruined the
project because she was so like
committed to being the one who wrote the
script or whatever I'm a very practical
person which is why when the original
sort of bidding war over the book came
out I said who's paying me the most
which is the most option because I know
the chances of it actually getting made
aren't that great so who's going to pay
me the most and um and somebody said
well this is we want this to be a
lifetime movie and someone else said I
want this to be a Warner Brothers movie
I'm like well lifetime is shooting lower
that seems more realistic let's go with
that so I just I just want I wanted it
to be made and if I was gonna stand in
the way of it being made because I
insisted on writing the script that
didn't make a lot of sense once I
realized I could actually do a good job
at it that's when I was willing to do it
how is writing a screenplay different
than writing a novel
I think
writing a screenplay if you have the
structure
it can really write itself once you've
got the structure down when you're
writing a novel
um it obviously there are many more
words on the page but there are many
more nuances descriptions character
development
um I think it is possibly
I think more people believe they can
write screenplays and try than people
think they can write novels and try I
think if you're gonna try to write a
novel you're probably going to succeed
and it's going to be pretty good
there are a lot of really terrible
scripts out there
is it because maybe
um there's so much you know thinking and
different things that you're writing
into the novel where you can't really
portray that within the you know sort of
the screenplay format you've got a more
it's difficult
I think I mean I I think this is like
every time I talk about the same thing I
think I think with with movies
um I think people aspiring authors are
probably going to be readers
who read a lot of books as opposed to
aspiring
screenwriters who are probably people
who like movies who maybe don't have any
history or experience with writing so
it's very easy to kind of be like oh
Star Wars that's a great here's my you
know Space movie idea whereas that
wouldn't last very long if you were
trying to do that as a book you'd kind
of it would fall apart pretty quickly I
think
what if a novelist doesn't have a skill
set to adapt their screenplay
if a novelist does not have their skill
set to adopt the screenplay stay the
hell out as out of respect for your own
work hope that the best writer is the
one who adapts it that being said you
know I know of stories where a writer is
such a big writer that they are given
that opportunity and you know get
somebody who really knows what they're
doing to supervise I mean you're after
the best version of your book not you
know getting in the writer's Guild or
having the glory of your name as a
screenwriter how does a writer know
their novel actually should be written
as a movie
I will say
I'll talk from my experience I've
written
um seven books and there's only one that
people always say should be a movie and
I guess the difference is that there's a
Twist and there's
um there's something about it that's
cinematic I honestly do not know I
didn't write that one saying oh my God
this is going to be a movie and these
aren't going to be movies I think
um I think it has to it you know I don't
know science fiction genre and all these
genres what I know are sort of the
movies that would be the books that
would be made into romantic comedies and
they have to have they have to have
vibrant characters they have to have
surprising twists they have to have do
you see this couple in the beginning and
you want them to be together but they're
going to be realistic obstacles that are
going to keep them apart
how often does a professional writer
write I believe that a professional
writer writes every day
I believe that it is one of those uh
skills it's sort of like the Malcolm
Gladwell 10 000 hour Theory uh that
you're not gonna excel at something and
be able to call yourself that unless you
do it all day every day and have for a
decade or so it kind of kills me I I
meet people all the time who say
everyone tells me I'm a great writer and
I say great do you write every day well
no I mean it's people don't really get
that it's like you know it's like going
into a gym and lifting weights one day
and saying everybody tells me I'm so
good at lifting weights well if you
don't do it every day how good are you
gonna be
what if someone's a Content writer for
their job let's say
and so they think that because I'm great
at writing copy or writing stuffer you
know a brand that then I can write my
own story it should be no problem I do
think that if you have experience as a
copywriter as a Content writer as long
as you're putting words together every
day you're going to be in much better
shape than someone who isn't any kind of
a writer but it is a totally different
skill set I think you know it's about
it's about words and language and
psychology I find actually uh
copywriters are very interesting to me
because the work is about I became a
writer because I'm fascinated with words
and psychology copywriters are all about
what's going to get someone to press by
what's going to get someone to have a
response so I actually think that's
better training than a lot of other
writing
and when you set out to be a writer
quote unquote you gave yourself what you
said three pages a day did that change
did you add on more to your plate no I
was always pretty committed to the three
three pages after rewriting the three
pages from the day before because that's
the thing that can take hours and hours
and hours I'm one of these writers who I
may over edit it's very easy to get very
caught up in like let me just make this
perfect let me just make this perfect
and it's sort of like perfect as the
enemy have done and you know
perfectionism is actually just fear
wearing a disguise it's never gonna be
perfect and when I meet people who say
I'm working on my book for seven years
I'm like oh God you might be better off
starting again
well what was her name Susan she wrote
uh quiet the power of introverts she did
Susan Kane yeah she did seven years but
she admits that she enjoyed the process
so much because she's an introvert and
it was right it was all part of who she
was so right right
right
okay what should a writer know before
writing their book a writer needs to
know why they're writing the book
um I wrote a lot of books without
knowing my why and it convinced me that
I didn't like writing anymore because
I had such bad experiences with it my
second book what happened is I had
written a story for detailed magazine
about high-class hookers in LA and I had
been given this assignment the editor
said go do what I'm giving you months go
infiltrate this whole CD underworld I
said great I went and did it I uncovered
great crazy crazy things and I had like
um I mean I had disk drives of things
that people been in prison I mean I had
lists of famous people I had the
craziest things and then my editor was
fired and another editor came in and he
said to me literally uh we just need
this to be a story about like how rich
men get off and so I was so bitter that
they had taken this amazing material I
had and made it into such a boring story
that
um my agent said to me was it was
actually when we were walking in to make
the deal for party girl she said they
may offer you a two-book deal do you
have another idea and so I just busted
out with how about a novel about
high-class hookers in Hollywood and they
said yeah that sounds good that's how I
got my second book deal
and I thought well sex cells it's a sexy
topic people are gonna like it I the
problem is I'm not interested in the
subject of hookers I don't have a
judgment about it I'm just totally bored
by it so I'm writing this book that I'm
bored by thinking oh sex cells I never
bothered to ask myself why do you want
to do if I'd asked it would have been
like well I want to do it because I'm
resentful at my editor details well
that's a stupid reason to do a book so
every author needs to say what is your
why why you why this book and why now
and if you can answer those questions
and you know what you want your reader
to do as soon as they finish writing it
then you should write your book
and of all of your books which was the
strongest why for you party girl party
girl was okay yeah it was it was
absolutely yeah
because you felt so connected to the
material because it was it was basically
you but you were sort of embellishing or
tying the other stories right yeah I
mean yeah party girl was very much my
story but it had it had a real it had a
real intention behind it and I wrote it
before I knew about Publishers and book
deals and Goodreads reviewers and nasty
comments and Book Sales and all the
things that were going to
um sort of
sadly poison the experience I it was
just written from such a pure heart what
is the process of writing a book begin
for you
the process of writing a book for me
today begins with
saying what am I interested in that
people actually want to know about and
not kind of having this vague idea but
really going out and trying out material
right now I'm writing a book that's
based on my podcast interviews and I put
out there on Twitter on LinkedIn on
Instagram I'm constantly kind of taking
the material I'm writing about and
seeing how people respond to it so
you're getting actual test cases you're
getting a b testing while you're working
on something so I need to I wrote many
books without ever bothering to ask if
anybody wanted to read them so now I get
really clear about is this a book people
are going to be interested in and then I
start writing from there
so you said with your second book you
weren't really that invested in the
topic yeah it was more because your
article was sort of kiboshed and you
thought you know what I no no I want to
take this were you surprised at the
feedback that you received that people
actually did want to know about this
like sort of The Client List or whatever
girlfriend experience
I don't
um no I I nobody really cared about my
second book least of all me I turned
that book in and I hated it and then a
month later I said can I have it back I
want to reread it from page one and my
editor said I don't think you need to I
think it's pretty good and I said no no
no I want to rewrite it and I rewrote it
and I rewrote it and I still hated it
and honestly when I get emails from
people who tell me they love it I have
no respect for them because I hate the
books so much
so do you think that's where there was a
disconnect that maybe because you didn't
feel so personally invested that it
translated and How It Was Written yeah
yeah party girl is I wrote this book
with this pure heart and there was so
much excitement around it and it was
going to be this thing it was going to
be my dream come true and then it didn't
happen and so I forgot about the pure
heart I thought well okay I gotta be
more strategic what will sell what do
people care about and I used to make a
really big mistake in my career which is
if somebody asked me
um to like to talk about something I
took that as a sign that I should you
know I became like a sex dating and
relationship expert despite having no
interest in it because somebody offered
me the opportunity to do it so my third
book was about reality shows because at
that point I was being asked to go on TV
and talk about reality shows I didn't
have a strong affinity for reality shows
I didn't really care but it was like I
was taking what was showing up as ideas
about what I should do and I really if I
have any regrets it's that I didn't just
stop back and go hey do you care about
reality shows nope okay next pack
another opportunity will come along
which is your favorite part of the
writing process that's such a good
question I used to love uh the very end
not because you were reaching the end
but because I'm not an outliner and so I
always feel felt like the end would it
was almost a spiritual experience where
it would make sense I would write myself
to a place where I'm like oh my God if
this hadn't happened here this could
never have like it was almost like
divinely inspired not to sound totally
pompous and self-important
um at this point
um
I do like all of it I will tell you the
part I like the least is actually where
I am with the book I'm writing right now
which is after I've Rewritten it and
printed it and gone through and made
edits and you're just like oh my God I'm
on page 200 Crossing things out to make
changes and you're so sick of the
material that's when it gets hard I have
found a trick which is
um when I'm so sick of reading my own
material it's almost like an acting
exercise pretend I'm somebody else how
would I feel if I was Karen reading this
you know and I almost try to embody
somebody else so that I can actually get
fresh eyes
what are the most common questions you
receive from new Authors the most common
questions I get are how do I become a
New York Times best-selling author how
do I get my book in bookstores and um
and how do I sell to a traditional
publisher every day I'm probably asked
all three of those things
and people are still caring about
bookstores people are still caring about
bookstores because even though you know
the bookstores are slowly going away
everybody has that experience of like
going to a bookstore as a kid or
whatever your your experiences are with
bookstores that there's something so
gratifying about seeing your own work in
a bookstore
what are the five biggest mistakes
authors make when writing a book
the five biggest mistakes I'm sure I've
made all of them uh number one not
asking who your book is for number two
uh focusing on all the wrong things like
the New York Times bestseller list uh
number three not bothering to find out
if it's a book people want or if it's a
book that if it's a topic that even has
a reading audience
you know
um number four they think that uh
because people have told them they're a
good writer that they should write a
book and
um number five there's nothing
unique about it
um and people I think oftentimes School
took a lot of the creativity out of us
my favorite comment I get from people
when they read my books is I felt like I
was hanging out with you I think a lot
of people they're trying to write in
some writerly voice and what it's
actually doing is making them very basic
and very much not sound like themselves
what stops most New Riders from writing
their first book I think what stops most
new writers is this question of who am I
to write a book why should anybody care
about what I have to say and I often
tell people my life's not that
interesting but I've made it into eight
books and hundreds of Articles it's not
about what it is it's about how it's
told which is why everybody may have a
book in them but not everybody should
write the book themselves if you can get
help from a professional writer do but I
think it's like if somebody says who am
I to to put my thoughts out there who
are you not to we live in a gatekeeper
free Society now where nobody has to
tell us where the chosen ones like you
can choose yourself so why not
how does a first-time writer find an
editor for their book and how do they
know that someone that's a match for
them
uh I I do I know almost no writers
who've had success out of the gate with
finding editors it is the hardest thing
because unlike say being a surgeon
anybody can say I'm an editor so I have
seen many books many clients come to us
and they say uh here's my book it's
edited and we read it it's awful and
they say but I but I hired this editor
and I say well did the editor had they
worked on best-selling books well I
never asked well what was their
experience what did and and they you
don't know what you don't know so when
you're looking for an editor the first
thing you should do is get not
necessarily references you don't need to
reach out to the people but find out
what books they worked on if they said
they worked on big books see if they're
actually thanked in those books
um if you can always give someone a
sample give them five pages and most
editors will do a sample so you can get
you know a sense of what they're going
to do and you need to understand what
editing is there's a developmental edit
which is uh chapter three belongs in
chapter 10 chapter 4 should not be there
this doesn't make sense then there's a
copy edit which is basically oh you
spelled this word wrong on this comma
and that thing and then there's a
proofread because even though the copy
editor is trained in copy editing is
still a human being so they're gonna
miss things we actually do an audio edit
where we have computer software that
reads the book aloud because the eyes
fill in words that aren't there so you
can literally five
experienced editors can look and still
like have a major word missing
um so they you definitely should not
trust anybody who says they're an editor
and if you find a good editor hold on to
them because they are hard to find
and what if you are continually told you
should write a book why you have great
stories but then you say to yourself
I don't know if I want to go that far
with some of these stories and then they
say well
but it'd be too interesting to you don't
want to leave this out this is this is
the meat of your book How do you how do
you reconcile that so you're told you
should write a book your story is so
interesting but there's certain things
you're squeamish about how far do you go
I um a lot of people uh are nervous
about telling certain parts of their
story particularly if they're running a
memoir and it involves other people and
this comes up all the time and people
will say to me oh I'm going to write
under a pen name because I don't want
you know
um I think it really really clear a lot
of us
um are constricted because our stories
involve other people and those other
people may not want those stories out
there or whatever it is
um I think only do what you're
comfortable with I have absolutely left
things out because in the end you know
if the people are still live I don't
think it's a good idea to put it out
there but um you know the nice thing
about the world that we live in today
with the way publishing works you can
put it out there and if you go you know
what I actually wish you know what I
feel more comfortable now now people are
thinking me as a writer I want to take
that back and add more remove it from
Amazon remove it from Ingram you can
redo it and re-upload it and all the new
copies will be that way I mean that's
one of the glories of uh not being
traditionally published you can change
your book at any time
what is a bismar
so my book make your mess your Memoir I
wanted to write a book about how to
write
but I didn't feel like I had a full book
in me and I thought you know I'm so I
can't just tell people what to do for
300 Pages that's so boring and I'm
somebody who a lot of business books
that I read I get a lot out of them but
I find them kind of boring and then
there are Memoirs I read where I'm
riveted by every page but I leave
without any takeaways or anything to
really do so I thought what if I could
combine them both tell my story that's
the Memoir part and then have four
chapters that are the business part
here's how you can tell your own Memoir
and so I coined the term Biz War
it hasn't really taken off yet but maybe
after this video it will
why is non-fiction or Memoir more
attractive to Publishers Than Fiction
I actually don't know that that's true
um I I don't honestly I don't know what
Publishers mainstream Publishers want
mainstream Publishers want what they
already know is going to sell so it's
not like you know if JK Rowling has a
new fiction that's very interesting
um they're just it's a business like
anything else so I don't know that
nonfiction is more attractive to them
Than Fiction but um they just want
what's successful
if no one reads your book you've written
a journal yeah I stole that line from my
friend Richard it's a good one it's my
same friend who said he feels so sorry
for people the week of their book
release
um I think that
without an audience
how audacious is it for you to think
people are going to read your book I was
that audacious I just thought well it's
out there obviously people are going to
care and the reality is you've got to
spend time nurturing finding your
audience making them aware of you making
sure they care about what your topic is
and then you actually write something
that you know that people want to read
and if you are reticent to go put
yourself out there again cool that just
means your book may be a journal it may
be a book no one reads if you want
people to read it you better be putting
yourself out there not just once but
over and over and over again telling
them about it
why do you say TV appearances don't sell
books
TV does not sell books because like
let's say
somebody on my podcast just said this to
me the other day let's say someone has
an exercise book and they go on The
Today Show and they go this is how
you're supposed to be doing sit-ups and
pull-ups somebody watching that is like
oh cool why do they need the book the
person just explained how to do it
a person has to hear about your book
between 8 and 15 times before they buy
it so if you're on the Today Show that's
a really big deal that's one out of 8 or
15 times
as opposed to a podcast where you are in
someone's ear maybe they're lying in bed
maybe they're walking they're do like
you are there with them it's a really
really intimate medium
people like if you're watching The Today
Show it's just sort of this like passive
thing it's on podcast you made an active
you had an active desire to listen to
that you are either so invested in that
host that you really trust what the host
says or you were searching and you want
to learn how to do something so it was
such it's the statistics on how much
better uh authors can sell books on
podcasts over books are ridiculous
how important are pre-sales
in the traditional publishing World
pre-sales used to be so important
because it determined what bookstores
were going to order now that bookstores
aren't that important
um they're less important here's why it
matters the way it works is let's say
your book is coming out in a month and
you're telling people now every single
book sale that happens between now and
that first week counts towards your
first week sales so if you're trying to
make the New York Times list
um and you can sell 10 000 copies
between your pre-order time and the
launch that's great for most people it
doesn't matter at all I am a big fan of
like the stealth launch where you
actually don't tell people the date
until the book is out because most of
our book sales happen on Amazon for
better or worse and the Amazon algorithm
really favors new books it really gives
a lot of juice to new books and and the
way it starts to work is if your book
you want people to buy your book that
are already interested in your topic so
that Amazon starts doing the what they
call the also bots so it'll say
customers who bought this also bought
this this this and this so
um that launch week Book Sales matter to
me a lot more than pre-sales
what can an author do to boost first
week sales
um
the best thing you can do to boost first
week sales is be everywhere but first
week matters so much less than first
month or first year I think a lot of
people think oh my God it has to be this
great success out of the gate because
that's what traditional it's for
traditional publishing
your book doesn't sell that first week
they're done they're moving on when
we're not dealing with that your book is
there for the rest of your life and the
tragedy I see is people work really hard
on their books and then they pay
attention to it for a week and then they
move on to the next that book is there
for the rest of your life so I say yeah
try to be everywhere all at once first
week but then try to layer promotion if
you have podcast interviews see if one
can come out week two another one week
three if you have people supporting you
by sending out newsletter lists like
and as Amazon likes that a lot what
Amazon doesn't love is a whole bunch of
sales one day and then nothing you know
drip it out that's going to be the best
thing for everyone so the drip method
yes I like that don't waste time on
forwards celebrity endorsements and Book
Sales
yeah I said that yeah I um I see so many
people obsess over I'm gonna get
so-and-so to do my blurb and I judge
them so much until I became that person
there was like this one person and I'm
like I know I can get her to the blurb
and no one cares I myself have never
bought a book because somebody blurbed
it ever ever ever so it's wonderful to
have that sort of social proof of
well-known people endorsing you but it
is not the most important thing forwards
are great if you happen to know a very
famous person who happens to know you
well and be associated with your topic
that's a pretty rare circumstance
otherwise you shouldn't do it the nice
thing about a forward is that on Amazon
they're listed as the co-author so we
have a book where Magic Johnson wrote
the forward so anybody searching for a
book by Magic Johnson this book is going
to come up
but I see people just sort of being like
Oh so-and-so like do my forward and it
doesn't even make sense
and then last but not least Book Sales
uh why don't Book Sales matter
because Book Sales you're making pennies
on the dollar if you are strategic about
it you are book sales accounting pennies
when you could be literally counting
Millions if you have
um an offer embedded into your book or
you your book shows that you are the
world's leading Authority on this so
people want to hire you it's just
focusing on Book Sales is focusing on
the wrong thing and when you say offer
you mean a link or a QR code that could
then hire you out for something yeah
yeah I mean just I think think of your
book as your calling card it is your you
know 200 pages to go convince the world
that you know about this topic and it's
not it's not like a crass business thing
it's just you should be paid a living
wage and if you're relying on Book Sales
you're never going to be unless you're
JK Rowling
would it work for fiction too
well no I mean it really doesn't that's
kind of
um it's really hard as a fiction author
to have a business that supports your
book I lucked into it with party girl
because it was I I was suddenly being
considered an expert in addiction and
Recovery
um but but normally a novel is not going
to lend you expertise
of the books that you've written Anna
how many had traditional Publishers and
how many were self-published
six were traditionally published and
then I've done
two between two and five I never know
what to count as a book when I can put I
you know I put out a journal two weeks
ago like does that count
um but I did six traditionally published
and the rest I published myself
is it worth it to self-publish a
thousand percent it is
um you need experts you need help
everybody Malcolm Gladwell has an editor
you need an editor
um you need a book designer you need
help doing the launch or maybe you're
just really good at research and you can
figure out I have met people who have
done Exquisite launches without having
any experience but most people are going
to need help
how realistic is it for most Riders to
land a traditional publishing deal
um it's really really hard to get a
traditional publishing deal now when I
first got in it was very different
um now the statistic that I hear is two
out of every 10 000 book proposals
submitted to Big Five publisher cell
those are agent represented
um if Publishers are not interested alas
in talent and unique ideas and amazing
Stories and it's not because they're
terrible people they're interested in
what's going to sell which is why the
people with all the following the people
with the big newsletter list the
celebrities that's who gets deals now
it's really not for that diamond in the
rough great idea
should it be a pageant of honor to have
rejection letters you know the whole oh
I'm gonna paper my wall you know my
bathroom with all my rejection letters
and that just shows like I'm gonna keep
going is that really a badge of honor
I'm not a fan of Gatekeepers my life got
so good
we're putting myself out there there to
say like hey am I good enough
um I take rejection really hard if other
people don't and they want to keep going
I mean that being said the people I know
who are successful are just the ones who
got up over and over and over again
success as a writer success is any sort
of creative I I actually don't think
it's about Talent it's about tenacity
it's about being willing to you know
being able to take getting knocked down
and getting back up again but I'd much
rather live in a world without
Gatekeepers where I can just make it
happen
what should a new author expect from
their publisher
very little
um I think that um
we all go into a traditional publishing
deal thinking that our publisher is
really behind us and I always liken it
to
um you know your filmmaker and your
writing and directing and starring
producing and and a studio gives you all
this money and you go and you make your
movie and they're like yes this is so
awesome this is going so great and then
it's the release day and no one from the
studio calls you back and you're like
but I don't understand you gave me money
we were in this together and then it's
just like
that's what it's like when you publish a
book you think because they've been with
you the whole time you think they're in
it with you and I again if you're
Glennon Doyle you're JK Rowling I'm sure
they are with the rest of us you just
are sort of like jumping off the diving
board alone so you better we all heard
that going in and thought it would be
different
um but even I've interviewed Robert
Greene like one of the most successful
writers of all time he's like your
publisher does nothing for you
given a choice would you rather
self-publish or have a publishing deal I
would rather publish myself over a
publishing deal any day because I have
published I have had books come out
where I hated the cover I hated the
title I hated sections of it and I was
basically giving away all my power for
absolutely nothing in return
um
that being said I mean like I haven't
had a big publisher come along and say
Here's a million dollars to write
whatever book you want it hasn't
happened I haven't been put to the test
but um I'm pretty I feel pretty safe
saying
um I will never traditionally publish
again
okay so that being said what are the
disadvantages of self-publishing
um
the disadvantage of self-publishing is
if you don't have people around you who
know what they're doing you're basically
going to put out a lesser product it's
not going to be written well it's not
going to be edited well it's not going
to have a great cover it's not going to
have all the things but if you uh want
to hire people to do professionals to do
all of that stuff it's going to look the
same as a traditionally published book
the other thing is these Publishers have
so many different divisions nobody knows
like
enliven is a division of Harper Collins
like no if you make up a name of a
Publishing Company nobody knows that
that's a big one or yours
okay so suppose me Karen wants to write
a book okay
I'm going to start my own LLC as a
publishing company is that correct
um yeah you actually I'm not a lawyer
but sure I don't know that you actually
need an LLC you can just make up a name
you go to a website called My
identifiers.com which is Bowker they
they give out all the ISBN numbers so
you basically go I think it's a hundred
dollars you buy an ISBN and you fill in
the name of the publisher and that's
what's going to go out a lot of people
screw that up and it'll say like
CreateSpace or KDP or independently
published you can make up you can make
name it after your cat and make that
your publishing company and that's
what's going to come up okay so yeah
again check with your attorney uh but we
don't know LLC or not but you can go and
get yours said it's an ISBN yeah okay
International standard book number and
then you can just fill in a name that
you make up make sure that someone else
doesn't already have that name do they
run a check I don't even know I don't
know okay and then there you go you're
you're now a publisher yeah and now you
need your book yeah so is that the first
step
I think ISBN comes down the line the
first step is have your elevator pitch
and I actually do have you can go to
bookelevatorpitch.com and I'll give you
this template it's my book is for blank
so that they can blank and that is your
step fill that out print it put it on
your wall put it everywhere remember
like your book is not about you it's
about them you're a reader so never
forget that
why is it important for an author to
realize no one cares about their book
it's important because
um as the author you have to make your
book fit into what's going on in the
world it's not news to anyone
when a book comes out so you know if
you're trying to get on mainstream media
which while it doesn't sell books is
really awesome promotion and social
proof and all of those things instead of
going hey news show my book is out think
how does this fit into the news when I
had my book make your mess your Memoir
come out July of 2020 Global pandemic a
book on writing is not news to anybody
but I so it was up to me to say how do I
make this news so I looked up statistics
about depression are at an all-time high
the numbers are terrible then I looked
up does writing help with depression
found numerous studies that said it I
wrote a press release and I said this is
the this is the news the depression
statistics are terrible writing helps
with depression this author Anna David
is available to speak about it and I got
that too good morning America and from
that I got a four minute segment on Good
Morning America there was nothing in my
book about writing helps heal depression
but it didn't matter that's what I
talked on the show about and the whole
time it said like New York Times
best-selling author of make your mess
your Memoir so it is imperative upon you
as the author to figure out where your
book fits into the news and not think
that your book is news in itself
and then reach out to the appropriate
Outlet yeah pitching yourself yeah I can
talk a little bit about how to do that
yeah that'd be great so in order to get
media attention definitely start with um
how is my book newsworthy uh try to find
studies try to find statistics try to
find Bookers if you put in Good Morning
America Booker a bunch of people's
linkedins are going to come up their
information is readily accessible there
are websites like mukrak and
Hunter IO
um you can find them on LinkedIn there
are ways to find out people's email
addresses the other thing you can do is
subscribe to Hero which is short for
help or reporter out and they send out
three emails a day and it's everybody
from like your mom's blog to the New
York Times They are looking for sources
and they'll say I'm looking for sources
to speak about depression about
addiction about movies about writing
whatever it is they send out three
emails a day look through the emails and
when something comes up that is relevant
for your topic you are an expert if
you're writing a book on a topic you're
an expert so reach out to that
journalist with the pitch on why you
should be in that story those are the
two best ways to get media attention